oui mais dire quelque chose annoncé tout
à l'heure j'ai voulu prendre une douche
derrière et docks et vous voir gentiment
m'a demandé s'il voulait me frotter le
dos quoi moi non c'est pas comme ça
c'est vrai quoi l on s'est vus après ou
camperait quoi après la douche parce
qu'elle prend des douches ici l accord
est alors elle est arrivée elle s'est
penchée je lui ai dit tu as pris de
douche 2 non j'ai dit pourquoi 2 ouais
j'ai dit elle est arrivée elle s'épanche
et a pris de douche elle a dit pourquoi
deux c'était quoi la bouffe et mahdia
mais non elle c'est arrivé elle s'est
penchée alors j'ai apprise de douche
mais ensuite après made in ore j'ai pris
une douche et à l'envié mais j'ai mis
plusieurs fois du savant j'ai dit non et
à ce moment là j'ai eu et dire et aurait
dû m'appeler je t'aurais rejoint la
liste d'attenté le dos et après on a
rigolé le comprendre mdr le bateau
le mois
cependant le bâtard mais l'attenté pas
pour devraient être ré dit oui tu aurais
dit j'aurais pas dit non c'est ou pas
tardé frotter le dos et rien arrêté
comment aussi le français parce que je
crois que le vôtre non je n'en sais rien
ta métro d'anono personne ne frappe
personne désert endormi amènes envers
l'île
je veux ouvrir lui est endormi mais sur
ces faits sont si bien réveiller lui les
bons sujets non mais c'est vrai
donnez-lui les bons sujets à traiter
quant à elle avait recyclé pour cette
révélation merci beaucoup
franchement adoré et serviable
visiblement déjà proposés vous non
castagné vous il vous a proposé à vous
et moi je me douche pas là de plus grave
c'est la raison
[Rires]